I'm Patrick Wilson class of 95 and I'm
the director of the full monty we are on
stage at the cha ski where Full Monty
will be playing very shortly well The
Full Monty picked me honestly you know
I've been coming here I mean I graduated
21 years ago and I come back
periodically to give master classes and
various things from my the musical
theatre or sometimes film stuff or just
sometimes just to talk to the kids or
help with their showcase and this was
really Gary Klein's idea of he said we
had they they had the class for it and
he thought it was sort of on a whim he
thought is there any way you would have
time or you would want to come direct
this and it just won it it just worked
out sometimes I think things are just
meant to be and I think me being here
and directing this we're just meant to
be
so I originated the role of Jerry on
Broadway so it's a show that I I know
pretty well did it for about a year
about 15 years ago
so understanding the show understanding
that it was sort of the next logical
progression for my doing master classes
I never directed before so this is a
brand new experience for me there's a
couple reasons I came back I am a big
believer in education I'm a big believer
in theater education a big believer in
Carnegie Mellon education my wife and I
met here my wife is the graduate class
of 98 and I anything that I could do
over the years to help young actors and
help their transition into the real
world whether it's through musical
theater film TV whatever it's it's
always been a priority of mine I think
some people just have that teaching bug
or and I have that I've always wanted to
to help I love when people came and gave
master classes when I was here that's
been kind of that's been super fun for
me working with Tom Douglas Tom came
when I was here and he was a voice
teacher and he just started I think
mites maybe sophomore junior year so
that's been amazing I've always known
Tom's a musical mastery and that's as a
student that's been that was always
thrilling and and
he's a such a talented guy to come back
and know that that was gonna be my
musical director and sort of understand
to you know if I have musical ideas that
I will you know and sort of us going
back and forth and what I think you know
we have a great understanding of things
everybody loves the piece so that when
everybody has the same focus there's no
ego involved in us you know which is
nice